here with reaction the host of life
liberty and Levin we call him the great
one Mark Levin is with us uh great one
how are you
um you have a great legal mind your
constitutional scholar you are the chief
of staff uh to Ronald Reagan's Attorney
General Ed Meese you know a lot about
the law uh let's get your take on the
law specifically in this case in this
indictment
well first of all one of the things on
top of everything else is there has to
be an underlying crime right Sean people
are saying well what is it
I'm saying well what underlying crime
did Donald Trump commit
he didn't commit any underlying crime
and he wasn't charged with any
underlying crime he wasn't charged with
federal election violations even though
that's not the jurisdiction of the D.A
there's nothing here but I want to get
into something here
Donald Trump is a historic figure or
they wouldn't be doing this they
wouldn't be doing this there wouldn't
have been a January sixth committee
there wouldn't have been a Mueller
criminal investigation there wouldn't
have been two phony impeachments listen
to this America there wouldn't have been
a warrant which is inexcusable and
unconstitutional warrant in my view and
FBI SWAT team sent to his home there had
been in the course of the last few
months five grand juries controlled by
democrats over what
you would have thought this man took
money from the Communist Chinese you
would have thought his son took money
from the Communist Chinese you would
have thought he's the criminal of the
Senate what exactly did he do so they
had to concoct all these phony crimes
because he didn't do anything
so the Manhattan D.A should be disbarred
not only because of the way he
campaigned because you know what this is
crap that a pre-law student shouldn't
even put in front of a damn judge that's
number one number two Leticia James in
Albany looking for crimes and then goes
after civil suits she's another one who
should be disbarred for the way that she
campaigned the legal profession is an
embarrassment right now the judges are a
humiliation right now they need to get
their ass in gear and get their act
together and get this country back
instead of giving a rubber stamp all
this Behavior that's number one we have
a Democrat attorney general in New York
a Democrat D.A in Manhattan a Democrat
D.A in Atlanta a Democrat appointed by
the Democrat attorney general for the
Biden Administration in Washington D.C
what's going on here this party wants to
change the Supreme Court they want to
change the Senate they want to eliminate
the filibuster will eliminate the
Electoral College they're attacking the
First Amendment they want to eliminate
the Second Amendment they're violating
the fourth and the Fifth Amendment you
know what this is this is tyranny
now Donald Trump is a historic figure
you think if he was Mitt Romney they'd
give a damn no
no you'd think if he frankly was a bush
that they'd give a damn no
look at Trump today he gives his speech
at Mar-A-Lago this is a man who's
committed to fighting these abuses who's
committed to fighting these marxists
who's committed to fighting the Tyranny
he talks about securing the Border they
don't want to secure the Border he talks
about sound money they don't want sound
money he talks about building up the
military they want to walk military he
backs the cops they hate the cops and I
could go on and on and on look what he
did to our economy look what he did with
energy Independence he was supposed to
be Barack Obama's third term with
Hillary Clinton and he stopped them and
this is payback and they're not going to
give up we the American people need to
stand behind this guy there's not
another Republican that I can think of
who can fight back and fight back this
way I can't think I like others
I really do I think some of them would
be great presidents but at this time at
this moment with these American Marxist
movements taking over with Soros funding
these prosecutors crime up the Wazoo
he's the guy and they know it and let me
tell you something else add one other
thing but Mr Bragg has
China is he's probably look at one
constant yeah look at what China is
doing look at as they try to fill the
void of course open
by America not leading the Free World
look at what's happening right before
our eyes look how dangerous that is and
the alliances that they're creating
and let me say something else while I
have a minute or so left
this D.A in Fulton County
Atlanta
is another hack
the idea that a president picks up the
phone and says something to the effect
find me some more votes and you're going
to say that that's a crime every
Precinct worker every Ward leader I have
no doubt that she's picked up the phone
and said the same thing during her
elections that's not a crime and this
jerk in Washington DC where they dragged
back from the hag was our horrendous
record of overcharging he's bringing in
service people and a secret service and
all the rest of our documents matter
over documents matter in Mar-A-Lago hey
we got documents we went in search found
more documents really so how the hell is
that obstruction the documents are still
there nobody destroyed them nobody sold
them to the enemy why are you acting
like this is the crime of the century
for God's sakes and then January 6th
they're trying to dust off old Civil War
statutes and Confederate statutes to
apply against a former president of the
United States the Democrat Party is
trying to destroy the Republican party
and they're going to succeed
if this works the Democrat party's
trying to choose the Republican nominee
the Democrat party has been hijacked by
Marxist radicals that's what this guy is
in Manhattan that's what they are in
Atlanta that's what all these fools are
and that's what's going on in this
country right now Victor Davis Hanson is
correct we are in a revolution and this
guy Donald Trump is standing up to it
like very few can and they are trying to
destroy him and you know what they're
going to do
they're going to make a martyr out of
them
because there's nobody else that could
stand up that doesn't withstand this day
in and day out the way he does
they're going to make a martyr out of
him for Liberty and I'm done that's it
and by the way it started from day one
when he came down the escalator and now
he's got a tsunami of of legal actions
again against him uh how anyone would be
able to bifurcate or compartmentalize uh
their time and attention to running a
campaign and dealing with all of this I
don't know how you do it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else